today's topic seems somebody wanted to
respond to a video we did i love the
argument i i don't even need to see it
i don't even need to see it to know what
the argument is which is going to be and
i'm going to tell you right now
the argument is probably going to be no
it is unnatural to be trans because
that's how it literally when you argue
with [ __ ] transphobes the only
argument they have is
relying on what other people also feel
about uh trans people because it's the
normative position to be [ __ ]
transphobic but the thing is the thing
is that's the thing and what we meant by
that
is
being trans is not
but transitioning is but whatever you
want
i just want you one better
it's not what we meant it's literally
what we said
i watched it back we didn't say being
trans is unnatural you said
transitioning is hormone therapy all
this stuff all of it's very natural you
know taking uh puberty blockers or like
like hormone blockers taking all this
stuff perfectly natural he really said
that transitioning is natural it's not
i'm not saying that this genitals 4 is
not natural that's not what we talk
about transitioning is nothing natural
it's like saying that things taking
steroids is natural
it's not i know yeah that was always
that's literally what we said i know
and and he's just not going to watch it
and demons transphobe so if if listen
dude if you're going to watch something
and do commentary with something said
and not watch what they said
and build a narrative
you haven't said anything
that's the dumbest way to do a tape
that's the dumbest way to dispute
someone's narrative or whatever i know
it's because you don't have any
arguments or whatever or not and you
raise yourself up oh this is what they
do
this is what they do that's what they do
you for someone that don't want to be
typecasted that's just weird that you do
that but whatever hey hey hey hey
you're just saying that because you're a
trans folk yes sure let's keep watching
god [ __ ] 10 hour
i covered the [ __ ] for like 10 [ __ ]
hours and they cut like 30 seconds and
go this is so stupid trans people are
weird and unnatural and then everyone's
like
mine
in here
dumb ass
abba and preach were the ones that were
dmca for criticizing fresh wait what
really they're actually i don't know
anything about them
so they are actually not bad what the
[ __ ] oh but they said my c word
ban was good like i deserved it and i
was a racist for saying uh cracker
that's also not what we said
what
what the [ __ ] hey man we have one
jordan peterson moment so what you said
was so what you're saying god
that's not what we said god just bit yo
i have nothing you know what let me just
give you what
no
just know just know this is so stupid
and that's not like you put work
that's how you build your narrative
you're just gonna lie about the whole
thing oh you stupid [ __ ] that's the
thing all right i really want i really
want
a [ __ ] to be able to explain to
me his point of view
that's just all i want
i want to have a conversation with a
[ __ ]
but no you dumb ass [ __ ]
you're just gonna invent [ __ ] you're low
low you in advanced [ __ ] that's what you
do
like what is it with you you're not
smart enough to dispute or just to say
which to take a point that someone says
and go on that point you gotta lie
it's easier to strum man like you stoop
that's is it because you're stupid or
you're not able to do it what is it
which one is it
you know you know your [ __ ]
you've been talking about that [ __ ] a
whole lot of time it's really simple
listen to what we gotta say and then go
on that but you gotta lie like how dumb
are you you know you're dumb you're not
you know you're not mentally capable
don't push me like that for me to stop
i'm not stopping uh
you know you're not mentally [ __ ]
capable of doing this [ __ ] is that what
it is what is it that's gotta lie
let's just watch the whole thing and see
what they got god damn
stop
no
no hey i remember one time we had a
[ __ ] conversation and you told me
about i told you i was i was i was on
your i was on you because of ghosting
it's like well you know why you go show
these [ __ ] explanations it's
like no i don't hold these [ __ ]
[ __ ] because they didn't have the
courtesy they didn't have the courtesy
to see that i was annoyed
and
they were annoying me and they were
getting on my nerves and they didn't
have no courtesy there so i don't have
to show them courtesy i have to show
this [ __ ] courtesy of listening
to his video when he don't listen he
don't bother he just makes it up hey but
but he's accusing us of doing the same
thing in that when we reacted to the
clip you get what i'm saying and so now
we've only reacted certain segment let's
watch it in its entirety all right and
then we can go in this is some stupid
[ __ ] we could go in we already went in
what i'm just saying
we don't even have to go in we have to
open the door and watch how [ __ ] [ __ ]
it is oh look there's [ __ ] must and
debris everywhere hey dookie smells like
dookie smells why not why is it assuming
the argument at least
because i made a [ __ ] promise that i
wasn't gonna engage with like idiotic
bad faith [ __ ] debates okay that's
why that's why
i think so he's accusing you of what you
accusing him he's saying we in bad faith
all this other stuff so
back and forth but he just he just
acknowledged that he didn't [ __ ] even
watch the video at least we went on what
he said
yeah and his statement in the vacuum was
idiotic it's not like we were looking at
his whole stance in totality that's why
because i know for a fact that it
literally doesn't go into any other area
it just simply is
i will do a thoughtful and [ __ ] you
know 30 minute to 40 minute analysis on
what they said what they got wrong and
then they will turn around and clip
something and basically uh you know use
that as a video opportunity
well what video opportunity like hold up
you're acting like we took a 30 second
clip and made a 10 minute video on you
you know i'm saying like if we just we
just took one clip as a more ensemble to
like showcase how stupid a lot of these
opinions surrounding transports are it's
not to say that i've reacted to his
entirety so don't get so butt hurt bro
that's why i'm i'm looking at this i'm
like bro the the the angle and the ego
you have to have to think like that
video was about you or to rebuttal you
is crazy to me you weren't in the
thumbnail you weren't the title you were
just in the video for like 20 seconds
breathe [ __ ] it's not that deep
but anyways
you know what this is what we gonna do
i'm good now you good i'm good now this
is what we're going to do we go watch
your thoughtful video and we'll see what
it's all about
it's over for me on that front like i i
am if you think that that's like me
running away from criticism then go
ahead
you are semi-correct they said
transitioning is unnatural but not being
trans oh okay got it
oh cool
oh
dude
so what you gotta say about that just ah
cool
bro that's cause you didn't watch a
[ __ ] video you know what no no no i
wanna watch it i'm gonna watch it i'm
good i'm good
go you're a kubecon uh comedian
so this happened to us
i'll i won't do the bad faith thing and
like not even look at their take because
now they're gonna clip that
and use that to be like oh he didn't
even see what we had to say oh we was
about to go in
yeah oh yeah so you know hey you know
you was about to create a moment ah
smart on you see you just proved to me
that you're not that dumb i i appreciate
you this is the thoughtful video he did
on the subject matter thanks okay have
you already covered that trans athlete
winning this living competition
genuinely just curious about your
thoughts on it my position first and
foremost is like i don't care and my
secondary position is like i think you
don't care either you're just like
trying to make an argument you're just
trying to debate about it and my third
and final position ultimately is that it
straight up does not matter absolutely
does not matter in the grand scheme of
things even if trans women were
completely dominating certain fields of
sport the only reason why you would
consider that to be completely
inappropriate and and unnatural is if
you think trans women are unnatural and
that's it
this is the thoughtful video here we go
and that is tech that is where
transphobia comes from which is
basically the the idea that trans women
are somehow not normal they're abnormal
they're weird i i get it like i
understand even if it does have a
competitive advantage i'm saying i don't
care because they're still a trans woman
you know what i mean i and i think that
trans women are women and that the only
reason why you consider that to be
unfair is because you think they're
doing it from a place of like uh
cheating yeah real talk
i feel like every trans activist just
walks into the room and sees the debate
going like you should hey yo yo i got
this i got this yeah i'm gonna shut this
whole [ __ ] down
trans women are women
mike try
hey you already know we got him hey hey
listen
trans women are women so you ain't gotta
say nothing and if you disagree that
means you transphobic that's what it
means
oh my god that's what are they doing
that's really what they do there's no
more argument than that
you know what trans women are women
fantastic but they're still not female
and at the other day sports is not about
your gender expression it's about your
sex your biology nobody cares about your
gender expression gender and sex are
different though we call it women's
sports it was really just about you
calling it female sports the reason why
is about physiology nobody cares about
how you express in the world so so to me
when people say well
i think they should compete because
trans women are women it doesn't matter
it's not the point of why we created the
category or why we sequester women to
this segment of society when it comes to
sports it's because biology biologically
speaking there's a difference that's all
it comes down to so i don't understand
why people say stuff like well you know
i i think that they should be able to
access these sports because trans women
are winning
that's not what it's about
we're talking about biology and
[ __ ] are still talking about
gender expression who cares
nobody cares what you identify as
not as far as this conversation goes
you're transphobic
because trans women are women
and if you disagree that means you're
transformed
social justice you like and the worst
thing is that we do agree
we agree we agree
but these things are separate but that's
not worth talking about if you go to the
doctors okay yes trans women are women
but guess what you still have the
physiology right and the biology of a
male as a result when you go to the
doctor that's gonna factor in they
shouldn't just be like well trans women
are women so i'm gonna treat you
it's a different ballgame so when it
comes to risk for certain diseases
different things they have to
acknowledge the fact that you're
biologically male
ma'am
you have ma'am you have prostate cancer
no trans women or women
you're gonna die you have to spam baby
you got testicular kids
no
no trans women are women that's not what
we're talking about yeah yeah you are a
woman that it doesn't it doesn't defeat
them well you know women are also at 75
risk for getting treats no males are
okay some aspects are more linked to
your biology than your gender expression
it's not a complicated thing it's not
transphobic to say this most people
would agree with this notion so i don't
understand why there's so much pushback
on life and it's fine but it's because
you don't care like you said you don't
care about the fact that this is unfair
you don't care about this you just want
to be able to say your [ __ ] spiel
from your political spectrum and then
that's it you walk away you good but
this is your thoughtful response
absolutely impeccable this is way better
than the clip i saw
like you you think that there's
something like mischievous going on
behind the scenes and like i personally
think that not a single human being on
the planet is gonna undergo hrt gender
confirmation therapy literally [ __ ]
like get brutalized by people over and
over again for just the crime of
existing have their existence be debated
on in in public by academics every
[ __ ] day just to win like swim
victories like you're psychotic it
reminds me of people who say what woman
would ever rake up a rape accusation
or a weinstein accusation well you find
out people will lie for anything people
will go through a whole ass double life
cheat on people who gave them their
kidneys do the most [ __ ] [ __ ] it is
possible do i believe that most of these
folks are doing that no but to sit there
like nobody would that's not true in
fact there's some people who claim to be
trans so they can get into certain
spaces and prey on people now of course
this is the minority of folks and i
wouldn't even say like that's a thing
but just like the wii spot incident
where it turns out the person who was in
those change rooms was an offender
there's some people who will use
whatever it takes to get to where they
need to go i'm not saying this isn't
this situation it's not something we've
ever said no but yeah no
i'm not going to talk about that yet
it's pure projection stop using misogyny
to defend trans women what i've never
but i've literally not done that i don't
know what because you said you don't
care about women's sports i mean i don't
cover any [ __ ] sports but anyone who
says that they don't care anyone who
says that they care about like high
school women's sports is just a [ __ ]
liar like absolutely a liar they're
lying to you
okay
so when people ask me about this right
do we care about high school women's
sports well who cares about high school
women's sports and the people who live
in that area traditionally do there's
plenty of high school teams that are
heavily supported by the local community
the alumni folks who come to watch
depends on where you live but this is
not a matter of like we care about each
individual high school sport or college
sports anything like that it's about the
principle of what we're seeing unfold in
front of us that's all it comes down to
so folks out here saying hey that
doesn't seem very right to me or fair or
doing it from a perspective like my high
school team was going to happen to them
most of us are coming from like yo we
see something that leaves
clearly unjust
and it just doesn't sit right with the
fact that everyone's everyone's closing
the eyes like it's the bird box
challenge because of some like political
affiliation get what i'm saying there
was a bird box challenge it feels like
it doesn't like [ __ ] was walking
in the street blindfolded
that's what it feels like
i'm mad at that that's what it feels
like it feels like that hassan i support
trans women in sports but please stop
with if they dominate women's sources it
doesn't matter it matters to plenty of
women athletes out there and they
and the way to fight transphobia is with
knowledge data's out there the most
trans women don't have a significant
competitive edge in sports let them
participate i mean i mention that all
the time as well that is not true see
see if you would have done a well
thought out response you would actually
looked into it because most studies and
the preliminary ones indicate that
there's some measure of advantage yes it
is measurable whether it be [ __ ] bone
density lung capacity all these things
most of the studies do that now there's
still more data to come out but
undoubtedly just judging by the fact
that like looking at how much more
successful trans women are compared to
trans men okay and just what the studies
that we have so far the science is
pretty indicative that
there's an advantage remember what i
told you last time
where the standard is trash
the test levels or whatever they have to
meet is like six times higher than
average cis women yeah so it's like
you're not even really making them do a
a a a real transition where they're
meeting like the normal levels of a cis
woman after one year so
i don't understand how folks can say i'm
doing a thoughtful response it's going
to be really good blah blah blah blah
blah
you watch it and it's like bro this is
full of nonsense and misinformation
but it's been full of misinformation how
am i how am i going to be surprised
that it's full of misinformation from a
guy
that is misinformed about us
thanks that he's spreading lies about us
and that we said some [ __ ] that we
haven't said there's some [ __ ] that we
haven't done putting words in our mouth
and now
i'm go i gotta be surprised that he does
this with numbers and statistics nah nah
i'm not i'm not surprised at all that's
what you do
whatever it fits your narratives you're
that's a that's a low key noble
that's a low key noble
yeah he lied he lies but it's for the
cause so it's good no it's not
no it's not you know you're making you
you're doing a big disservice to the
cause that's your serving by being
low-key noble by lying like that you're
lying you're straight up lying
and that's precisely why i always say
like even if they were dominating which
they usually aren't um even if they were
dominating who cares trans women are
still women you don't have this kind of
attitude towards like any sort of tall
people who are naturally tall you don't
have this sort of attitude towards messi
who had to literally take supplements
and steroids specifically to i think
what is it like combat early onset
dwarfism if i'm not mistaken like you
cherish people when what the [ __ ] did he
just say
you don't have this attitude towards
tall people or leonel messi who had to
take some injections with the kid to
combat dwarfism
so basically he has like unfair
advantage because he was giving steroids
to the kid
oh man are we done
hey bro
listen cause the thing is this go for it
talk to me like i said before in every
freaking videos we do on this [ __ ]
subject right
there's nothing else
i'm gonna say yeah that i haven't said
yeah i agree
i i don't know exactly about
it feels like you're just smacking your
head against the wall straight up yeah
yeah yeah but for some people they like
a bit of that pain i think i'm one of
those people
like like you don't think i know i've
repeated some lines yeah yeah yeah i'm
like oh [ __ ] i said this verbatim last
night yeah yeah i don't remember
them even like some of the audience
members are probably like mouthing the
words before they even come out they
know they know they know we know
yeah
yeah
so we don't technically speaking there
is no such thing as men's sports this is
just sports sports and there's female
sports
if women could compete in the male
diamond they can join they can but they
can't
and so we segregate them yeah it's not
because there's mints there's no such
thing as men's sport there's no men's
tennis
there's tennis and there's women's
tennis serena williams doesn't exist
without women's chemist she's not
getting no wit dubs no wins nobody cares
that's not our word by the way that's
hers that's not our words that's the
roll the clip that's not us that's right
that's her thing that's her actually
it's funny because andy murray he oh he
was been joking about um myself and him
playing a match and i'm like andy
seriously like are you kidding me
because for me tennis in men's tennis
and women's centers are completely
almost two separate sports so i'm like
if i were to play andy murray i would
lose 6060 in
five to six minutes maybe 10 minutes
because
no it's true it's a completely
it's a completely different word the men
are a lot faster and me and um they they
get they serve harder they hit hard it's
just a different game and i love to play
women's students and i i only want to
play girls because i don't want to be
embarrassed i would not do the tour i
wouldn't do billie jean any justice so
andy stop it yeah we're not gonna i'm
not gonna let you kill me so whenever
john mcenroe was saying oh she's the
best female uh tennis player
she said that herself anyways let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you